Did you know that people think that Egyptians were the first civilization that started manufacturing colors?
They're known for their use of Egyptian blue.
They would make blue glass out of copper and sand, and then grind it into a powder...
...and mix it into a rich blue paint.
They also made green paint by grinding and washing a mineral called malachite.
The Egyptians would apply their paint using brushes...
...that they made out of plant fibers and small twigs.
You can see paintings from the Egyptian period covering their tombs and pyramids.
And although paper, as we know it, wouldn't be invented for hundreds of years,...
...they also painted on sheets of papyrus,...
...which was a paperlike surface that they created from strips of fiber from papyrus plants.